para hablar de este país que tanto
amamos esta tierra de promesas y
oportunidad de héroes y de grandeza hace
unos meses atrás estamos viendo el sueño
eeuu convertirse en realidad
para muchos de los ciudadanos
la mayor expansión económica de la
historia de eeuu la menor tasa de
desempleo en la historia es para
hispanoamericanos afroamericanos y las
mujeres y casi para todo otros grupos
demográficos luego vimos el virus que
llegó de china el presidente decidió
prohibir los viajes de china zhou vaivén
y sus aliados democráticos llevaron a mi
padre como un ser xenófobo y racista
afortunadamente mientras el virus empezó
a esparcir presidente actuó rápidamente
y entregó los respiradores a los
hospitales que necesitaba baños y él
pidió al sector privado para que ayudara
en este nuevo reto hay una luz al final
del túnel
las políticas de vaivén de izquierda
radical está diciendo que quiere volver
a cerrar el país esto es una locura los
demócratas
dicen que son para los trabajadores pero
no pasa toda la pandemia son muy bien
tratar de subir los impuestos y luego
quieren atacar a mi padre por suspender
los pagos a los trabajadores de clase
media si lo piensan
joe biden toda la plataforma económica
está diseñada para destruir a los
trabajadores el voto por el acuerdo y el
apoyo por el chip y adiós a los trabajos
de manufactura
es tan débil ante china que el partido
comunista de china favorece y valen
porque sabe que nos va a debilitar a
nivel mundial
quiere que vengas más inmigrantes
ilegales para tomar trabajos
él ha dicho que quiere repeler los
recorte de los impuestos que ha sido el
mayor en nuestro país luego de la lenta
el decrecimiento de obama y bailén las
políticas de toms han sido como un
cohete creciendo vaivén así ha prometido
sacar ese dinero de su bolsillo y
mantenerlo
él ha trabajado siempre de vez en cuando
para este presidente luego desaparece y
no hace mucho
así que si buscan experiencia busquen al
hombre que ha dicho lo que la
administración obama y byron nunca
lograron y construir la economía más
grande que nuestro país ha visto el
presidente camps lo volverás
vamos a hacer más fuerte que nunca
porque cuando nos enfocamos en ello no
hay ningún obstáculo que ningún
estadounidense puede sobrepasar reports
visto excepto que hay una diferencia
esta vez en el pasado
los dos partidos creyeron en lo bueno de
eeuu estábamos de acuerdo en lo que
queríamos pero sólo estamos en
desacuerdo en cómo lo lograríamos esta
vez el partido se va está atacando las
fundaciones y las bases de eeuu la
libertad de religión la libertad de
expresar de expresión
a nuestros fundadores creyeron que no
era más importante que proteger nuestro
derecho para pensar por nosotros mismos
ahora la izquierda lo que están tratando
es de eliminar todo eso no parecen
entender este principio para poder
mejorar el futuro debemos aprender de
nuestro pasado no borrar nuestro pasado
así que no vamos a destruir monumentos y
olvidar a las personas que construyeron
nuestro país en cambio vamos a aprender
de nuestro pasado para no repetir los
errores y vamos a trabajar para mejorar
la vida de todos los estadounidenses joe
biden y la izquierda radical ahora
vienen por nuestra libertad de expresión
si ellos logran lo que quieren no va a
ser la el cis la mayoría del silencio
sino la mayoría va a ser silenciado esto
debe detenerse la libertad de expresión
debe era un valor fundamental el partido
republicano es el lugar de la libertad
de expresión donde cualquiera
y hablar y puede hacer que sus ideas y
las mejores ganen las personas con fe
están bajo ataques no pueden ir a las
iglesias pero el caos en las calles
puede pasar
es como si estas elecciones
de la iglesia el colegio las comunidades
contra el vandalismo las protestas y su
protesta o como dice vaivén y sus
aliados las protestas pacíficas
los pequeños cubanos en eeuu la mayoría
y minorías están sido demolidos por
hambre
las protestas dicen que es un enero del
amor un verano del amor
en todos los estados unidos-
estadunidenses debe vivir sin miedo en
las comunidades y en sus hogares todas
las mujeres y los hombres fueron creados
iguales y fuertes y deben ser tratados
bajo la ley por eso debemos terminar con
el racismo y asegurarnos que cualquier
policía que abusa de su poder tiene que
responder ante la justicia lo que pasó
fue horrible y si alguna con policía van
a acordar hasta estar de acuerdo en esto
ellos merecen nuestro aprecio nuestro
porque no sin importar lo que dicen los
demócratas usted y yo sabemos cuando lo
llamamos al 911
no queremos que vaya a un buzón de
mensajes desmantele desmantelar la
policía no es la opción del jugador
no podemos tener nada sin la seguridad y
la protección
no podemos ver si los niños pueden jugar
en sus
barrios y dormir tranquilamente en sus
camas pero la protección y la seguridad
son el comienzo la tierra de trump es un
lugar de promesas de libertad yo pude
crecer en una familia donde me podían
otorgar la mejor educación en las dos
mejores y más universidades pero esto
debería ser accesible para todo el mundo
y por eso mis padres dice que él ha
pedido que la educación accesible es un
tema clave para todo el tiempo es
inaceptable que afroamericanos
hispanoamericanos estén en malas
escuelas sólo porque así es
no lo va a permitir si los demócratas
deberían ayudar a las minorías
deberían dejar elegir que en sus padres
elijan cuáles son las mejores escuelas
para que sus hijos vayan juntos ellos
deberían apoyar a los policías que
protegen nuestros barrios debería
aprender a negociar
que pongan a los intereses de eeuu
primero y terminar estas guerras y
terminar años de enviar a nuestros
jóvenes para solucionar los problemas
que ellos mismos crean
invest in intinere cities
en otras palabras si los demócratas les
importaran las personas de eeuu harían
exactamente lo que estarías lo que está
haciendo el presidente de donald trump
eeuu el país más grande del mundo pero
mi padre la visión de mi padre y wenger
es que nosotros siempre podemos hacer
mucho mejor imagínense lo que lo que
puede tener un gran trabajo o un gran
hogar una gran familia usted lo puede
tener imagínense el país en el que
quiere vivir donde hay oportunidades
igualitarias donde hay trabajos bien
pagos y usted puede tener eso imagínense
un mundo donde la maldad del comunismo y
es lo mismo no tienen la oportunidad de
crecer donde los héroes son celebrados y
los buenos ganan usted puede tener eso
esa es la vida este es el país este es
el mundo que donald trump y el partido
republicano quieren y sí
puede tenerlo porque hay a diferencia de
sopa y de la izquierda a radicar nuestro
partido está abierto para todo el mundo
que comienza rechazando a todos los
radicales y dándole bienvenida a los
hombres que representan un futuro
lindo para todos nosotros pues empieza
como donald y jason como presidente de
eeuu
acá pues gracias y que dios bendiga a
estados unidos